all right hi everyone believe it or not
this is actually the second time I've
been to one of your meetups I went to
one in May and just like kind of hung
out in the back and pretended like I
knew people but I didn't but it was
still it was a really great event so I
didn't mind yeah so um animation is the
thing I end up talking about a lot which
sort of makes sense considering it's in
the title of this talk and it's in the
name of my book but I have a somewhat
unpopular opinion sometimes with web
people about web animation where I think
it's something we should use more and
there are definitely people around the
internet especially on Twitter who think
that's a terrible idea
mostly because well people like to argue
on Twitter but I have realized
yeah maybe you've noticed that I
realized when I when I've talked to some
of these people like a lot of clients
I've gone into there be like we want to
bring you into our office because our
creative director hates animation and
could you convince him he's wrong um
usually they tell me this about five
minutes before the actual workshop
starts so I get lots of warning but I've
realized folks like that the reason why
they hate animation or are so against it
is because they think if we use more
animation on the web we'll end up with
an entire Internet of sites like this I
mean this is a video it's a little hard
to tell what I'm doing but I'm scrolling
down the page to read some content I
have no idea what's on this page and
then it'll happens to get backwards when
you scroll up and it's like we could if
we all collectively decide we want a lot
of spinning paragraphs I mean there's
enough of us in here we could start a
web design trend and we can be like
that's what happens paragraphs roll into
the page as you scroll that is good it's
like we could make the entire web look
like this by using animation but we
could also you know like maybe have
slightly different goals because other
sites there's other sites that use lots
of animation for example stripe check
out which has a ton of animation in the
entire checkout flow there is
I don't think one single interaction and
the entire flow of like buying a thing
with stripe check out that doesn't have
an animation associated with it there
may be one or two there's even some 3d
animations and 3d flips and all of this
stuff but this feels a whole lot
different than the site before it and
the thing that's different about them I
think it's different about stripe check
out versus that first site isn't the
number of animations there's still a lot
of animation it's the way that the
animations and stripe check out like
have an intentional purpose for being
there and a purpose that thinks about
the person using the check out not just
like the person being like we can flip
things around and CSS you're like
they're thinking about who's gonna be
using this and they're thinking about
what their goals are and how they can
you know like help them reach their
goals easier and get their tasks done
faster and so there's there's a lot of
intentional purpose to their animation
they've really thought about why all
that stuff is there they've also really
designed it well like it just fits well
with the rest of their design there's no
like one bit of animation that you're
like oh wow what the heck was that they
just have a great you know a cohesive
feel to the whole thing so if we wanted
to make more animation like the stripe
animation style you know making that
animation that has a really well-known
purpose and in encino design well really
what all of the sites like stripe isn't
the only place all of the apps and sites
that have really great UI animation the
thing they have in common is they're all
combining this like this combination of
purpose and style you know the
animations there for a reason and it's
like a user based reason and then they
just pull it off really well so tonight
I want to talk mostly about the purpose
side of this because I think that's the
harder part I mean a lot of us when we
see good animation we can we know when
it's good but it's harder sometimes when
you're looking at your own work decide
where it makes sense to use it and how
it could be useful so we'll go over some
some good purposes of animation one of
the first one of the I guess what's the
first one in my list but one of the
major ones that where animation can be
super helpful is in helping establish or
or keep orientation and keep continuity
going of like helping people realize
where they are I don't know if you've
noticed but there's a lot of different
screen sizes our work end ends up on
these days all sorts of things giant
monitors like this one that's almost as
big as the one I have on
dezq kind of miss it like you know we
have the giant monitors we have the tiny
tiny ones we have like the tiny tiny
ones and there's probably smaller ones
than this so we're covering a lot of
ground when it comes to size and often
times we can't fit our entire interface
on one screen so we end up like layering
things behind each other having some
stuff off screen and essentially
creating like a world of the interface
but can't all be seen on screen so
animation can be a thing that helps
inform the user of what that map is
generally the people like for the people
designing it we know like oh that menu
is off there and that things down there
well we don't always make a good effort
to like expose that to people using the
the interface in the end so some
examples of this is like cotton Bureau
on where you can buy shirts on their
site and they have this whole like flow
where their navigation is off the left
and their cart flow just keeps coming
through from the right step by step but
the whole time because they actually
like pan the site across you you know
where those other things are like I
can't see their navigation anymore but I
still know how to get to it because of
the way this is moved and I still know
how to get back to the shirt I was
looking at because I actually saw this
flow if they just suddenly cut over like
half a shirt I'd be like what what is
even happening so that tiny bit of
transition is really what gives that
information of like hey we're just
moving over here it's still attached and
they also create that very physical like
you know everything's together and
you're kind of just like moving behind
your viewport sort of thing Google Fonts
does this really well in their new
design which I guess isn't all that new
but it's so much better than the old
design I love it where they have kind of
two layers of their interface like one
where you pick fonts and then one where
you actually have your selection and
like do active things with them so you
can like pick some fonts and once you
select them they end up in that little
drawer on the bottom and that little
drawer is kind of where you can
customize your selections and do
whatever else and you know download it
or get the code to embed it in your site
and those are all kind of like the two
different purposes of the layers of
their interface so they keep you you
have a pretty good sense of orientation
when going around that they also do a
really great sort of like keeping of
like switching between context as well
in their little Paint Bucket icon where
they make it seem like all the colors
are coming out of the Paint Bucket just
with that little like thing you're like
oh well then they go back in
Paint Bucket and you can change it
really great colors like white or
obnoxious yellow whatever you want and
we get the sense of like those color
chips are living in the Paint Bucket
icon and like we know it's really not
cuz we know it's just pixels and that's
not really happening but it gives it
that physical sense of like hey that's
where these are you know exactly where
to go and get back to them and gives
them all a good nice like purpose and
just consistent place of being gives it
almost almost like a sense of
physicality you're like okay I would
open my paint book there it is you can
also use this animation to switch
between contexts to essentially save
space this is probably never happened to
any of you but sometimes if I go to fill
out a form that has the option of either
paying with credit card or PayPal I'm
not paying attention and I end up
filling up both forms because I'm just
like tab tab tab Gumroad does a really
nice thing to make both avoid that
possibly from happening avoid like
making it easier to avoid errors and
also making their forms seem really
simple by just having a simple 3d flip
between the two different ways of paying
so if you're like I think I want to pay
with PayPal no credit card oh I don't
even know I guess PayPal oh that was
actually it was going on my mind while I
was recording that um but they've made
their payout from there like payments
page look really simple and it's really
obvious you're like one side or the
other it's one or the other it's not
both you just pick one and everything
stays nice and simple and they've got
that that connection between you know
like the back or front two different
things two different options so they do
that really well kind of along the same
lines of orientation and continuity is
the idea of visual continuity which is
essentially the idea of like making the
thing on screen actually be a thing I
think that's at the core of it that's a
lot of what we do with motion is make
the thing that we know is just pixels
seem like a physical object in some way
and it's you know we have that aim and
other design areas too but visual
continuity can be an interesting one and
and when we don't see on the web a whole
lot partly because of the whole idea of
loading pages but often times we'll have
a bunch of things on screen and then
we'll send them all off screen just to
bring them back on again and you're like
why did it leave just to come back good
question I don't know so some ways to
avoid
that or to kind of avoid breaking that
continuity not that it's a bad thing to
do but when things leave and come back
someone viewing that has to make a
decision of like is that still the same
thing I was just looking at if it stays
on screen they know it was so one of my
best the best examples I've seen of this
is an old design of the Twitter app but
when you switch between your accounts to
go to a different one
your avatar stays on the screen and just
moves to its new position so as they're
switching accounts you always know
exactly which one you picked there's no
like you know full screen wiper you're
like wait which one did I click on just
moves up to the new place or moves back
down depending on which context you're
looking at this can also work really
well the idea of visual continuity can
also work really well with gestures this
is a demo from David Cordish where he
has you can actually like swipe to pick
the menu items and the menu items
actually move with you so they have both
like a horizontal and like a stacked
version but you know that like that
gaming option is the same one you're
looking at because you actually drag it
with you and it follows you through that
gesture but the main thing there is the
fact that it's staying on screen you can
see them rearrange means you don't have
to second-guess whether they're really
the same thing so it's a great technique
to use another thing animation is really
useful at is giving feedback which is
kind of I hear an important thing
sometimes if you want people to know
that stuff happened I don't know I think
that's probably a good thing to do
stripe does this nicely with a nice
light kind of physical sense of an error
message where if you try to like do
something wrong in there for more like
submit an empty form it actually just
kind of shakes his head at you it's like
oh no you can't buy things if you don't
fill in the form
silly human but you know in that sense
it's like a nice they have that nice
physical reference of like oh silly you
know it's an error and they also even
though this is a desktop version on
their smaller screen version where they
can't fit the whole thing that you could
actually see the shaking but he was that
same animation but with a nice red arrow
so they have that consistent feel across
different viewports it's the same feel
the same motion but it actually fits the
space better so they're like that extra
bit of feedback of like you've made a
mistake it's not the only thing telling
you there's an error but it's probably
at least for a desktop version in this
case
one of the most noticeable depending on
what how you're accessing the site
animation can also let us give feedback
in a smaller amount of space I'm instead
of using like physical space to give
feedback like when you're like okay it's
loading okay it's done loading now we're
doing the next thing we can use like
time as space to do it and that saves
you a lot of physical space so this is
stripe checkout as well and when you pay
or donate they have the same button be
essentially your like pay button you're
like loading state and your success
state all in one place conveniently the
place you're probably looking if you
just click to donate so as you go to
donate your dollar you get your loading
and then they're like and success all in
one place instead of adding like extra
little banners or anything they've
accomplished it in a small space but
it's still giving the same feedback and
it's still very effective animation can
also be used for a feedback on you know
maybe less I don't know is paying or
less dramatic stuff like just checking
out and doing something that that big
but also kind of giving you a more
subtle indication of like where you are
in a document this one is conveniently
about taking a really long plane rides
they use a little plane to show you
where you are I'm like all that's so
clever so it fits really well but gives
you a sense of like where you are in
this giant article or this giant plane
ride kind of along the same lines of
feedback animation can be really useful
for giving you giving you essentially
like hinting at affordances and the
things that you can do not necessarily
the things that you've triggered or
things that are happening there's a lot
of this I think when it comes to various
interfaces where things maybe you're
trying something a little different or
trying to have some features for like
these power users or people who use
things a lot and maybe are really
familiar with your app and they maybe
could do things faster if they knew like
this one little trick or whatever else
essentially you know these these new in
hint tech features that are there or
abilities that exist that people might
not know about and also how people see
like the cause and effect of what
they're doing of like giving them a
preview almost of like what will happen
before they finish the action so i OS
did this really nicely when they switch
the camera the way the camera worked
where you used to just like tap on the
camera icon
open your camera and then they change
that they're like no you have to swipe
on the camera icon now and we're just
gonna make the tapping stop working what
you know may be a questionable decision
but whatever so if you went to tap on
your camera icon after you did that i OS
update you would just do this it just
kind of does this like hints of the
gesture it's like no try sliding me up
and like you kind of gives you that hint
of like what you should do that gesture
that movement you need to make and also
it gives that sense of a physical space
as well where when that your home screen
slides up you see the little button for
the camera so it's like it's also
telling you like the cameras back here
waiting for you just learn to swipe up
and you're good
of course they completely ditch this
entirely in the most recent update but
that's okay it was still a good it's
still a good design choice clear does
this well there are to-do list app both
on I found and a desktop app where
there's essentially like no buttons or
anything in this interface you just kind
of like do stuff and it's all done all
the feedback and all of the interactions
are done with like motion or gestures
and sound so as you're like you know
you're you're kind of making your to-do
list as you keep typing or as you move
your cursor near the bottom it's just
like hey do you want to make another
to-do list and it gives you that sense
it like everything is stacked up behind
and just folding down but you don't
actually have to go hit a button you
don't even actually have to start typing
the next one before it hints that you
know when you get in here at the end of
the one you're typing it's like oh would
you like to do this if you keep going
you'll get more list items so it's very
effective and even just kind of very
subtle to be like you can just keep
going you don't have to worry about what
you do next
drag-and-drop interactions do a ton of
this and it's one of those ones where I
think we don't realize it because we've
probably used so many drag-and-drop
interfaces we don't realize how many
little bits of feedback are involved in
a good drag-and-drop interaction and
then you go to like make one and you're
like oh my goodness this is really hard
like this is why people write libraries
for this
who knew but there's a lot of bits of
hinting that you can do in a
drag-and-drop interaction and then that
make it feel like a good interaction for
example this is Google keep they do it
pretty well where when you're dragging
stuff around it gives you a little hint
of like what things might look like
before you actually drop it
also gives you that sense of like depth
of where your stuff is and the biggest
thing it's doing is like giving you that
preview of what it's going to look like
before you actually drop it giving you
that sense of cause and effect so you're
like oh do I really want to put this
here no maybe I don't you can kind of
back out a bit before you actually do it
which is pretty helpful kind of related
to that is using animation to guide
tasks which is really powerful way to
well show people what they can do or
what to expect when we're doing this
with motion
kind of giving them a sense of what
they're actually able to do and sort of
where they are in and maybe perhaps like
a complicated multiple step situation
Google Docs does is super well when
you're moving documents around this is
actually my Google Docs folder and I
totally only have four documents in one
folder it's not a giant mess that I've
cropped out of this screenshot of course
not but when you collect up documents
and try to move some things around in
Google Docs they actually have a quite a
bit of animation helping you out along
the way so if you go and collect up a
bunch of documents they're like okay
they all kind of like scoop together
this pile you get a nice little number
for so you know I got four documents and
then my favorite part all the documents
jump back in space into the folder and
it's like it's kind of complex motion
right it's like 3d perspective II stuff
it's all jumping back in the folder and
even though a nice little pile that
they've got so it's a lot of little bits
of information along the way that
they're doing with motion to help you
realize what you're what you've got
going on you're like okay I've got four
documents I'm always going to know that
because of what they provided for us
before me have I know it's a stack and I
know it can go into that folder because
it turns blue and then they also go jump
back in which is pretty fun a fun note
on this one is that they originally did
this interaction in Google+ which is the
social network Google made that I'm sure
everyone uses lots and that was even
before material design it had like a
paper clip and everything that it was in
it and then they moved it over to Google
Docs and material design if I'd it
I guess maybe they thought no I'm just
using it in Google+ I don't know but I
think it works out really well here to
you and even with a with without the
paperclip it's still good
we can even use motion to like help
guide tasks in a way that like probably
borders on the like surprise and delight
situation and I know some people think
delight is a terrible word to use or
either people think delight is a
horrible word to use to describe
animation or they think it's the only
word to describe animation I've met very
few people who are in the middle of the
road on that but doing things that might
be considered delightful can still be
really useful this is a forum or our
site rather that sells you like pre
home-cooked dog food for your dog so
your dogs on eating kibble some human in
a kitchen in San Francisco is cooking
your dog a home-cooked meal I mean I
would never do this but yeah like who
would right um so they need to get a lot
of information from you they need to
know a bunch about your dog they need to
know a whole lot about you and they
could have given us or you know the
hypothetical person filling out this
form could have gotten like a giant like
multiple screen long form for all the
information they needed or they could do
stuff like this where they just kind of
bring in each new thing as you finished
up the last one it kind of makes it feel
a bit like a conversation like just
before you finish the last one the next
question comes in they're like okay
let's just go to the next place and then
they started asking you questions about
your dog and you're like culturally
hooked at this point you're gonna do it
all and you're like oh yeah I think it's
a lot of personal information about my
dog and then this is a really hard
question you're like what word would I
use to describe her but it's like I mean
there it this ends up being a few
screens long it's just the way they kind
of bring things in like to use that
timing that makes it feel like a
conversation it makes it feel like
but each task you have is very
bite-sized even though they've asked you
for a ton of information yeah my dog
didn't like the food in the end that's
okay maybe there was an option there for
most spoiled we can also use another
what kind of surprise and delayed ish
way of using animation or not even that
of really this is more about guiding the
task at hand that just happens to also
be delightful delight is not the purpose
this animation is there but it just also
happens to be um this is an app called
readme who happen to have a
an owl as their mascot and their mascot
makes an appearance an animated mascot
makes an appearance in their login or
signup form now animated mascots make me
feel a little bit weird because I've
seen that go horribly wrong I'm sure you
all have to if you've ever used Clippy
Microsoft Clippy generally that's made
anyone think of like a talking character
on screen just be like oh I don't know
but you know then they could have gone
that direction this owl could be like
hey looks like you're trying to sign-in
would you like my help something about
like hoot or something I don't know some
terrible pun when you can be jumping
around and all of this stuff and that's
one way to use an animated mascot but
instead they just have them be there to
help you fill out the form and know
which field you're actually filling out
so as you go through it he's just like
next field next field oh you're like
kind of like that owl
I mean his little eyes and feather
aren't the only thing showing you what
field you're in they still got the nice
you know like proper accessible outline
and everything but they've added just
enough to it it's like they're to help
you look you probably know when you're
filling out those three fields maybe but
who knows if you're distracted or
whatever else not know not used to these
sign-in forms he also makes an
appearance when you go to log in after
you've created an account where he's
just like hanging out there on the top
of the page when you tabbed your
password field he covers his eyes with
his feathers it's the best I love that
one
I'm just like tab tab tab and making the
Owls do this over and over be like both
this one and the the form before it the
intention behind that animation was very
much focused in like helping you get
your stuff done but they've also created
this sense like made it a little bit
more fun to even in places where you
don't necessarily have to because who's
ever set a form on the internet was fun
no one another thing animation is super
great at is directing attention in fact
this might be the thing it is very much
the best at and both like the thing that
makes it so great and the thing that
makes it potentially so like I don't
know not so great if you kind of think
of all the design tools we have at our
disposal and we're making interfaces
things like color type all of that stuff
I feel like animation is the one that's
almost always talking with its outside
voice right like you could create really
obnoxious color
nations and people will be like okay I
got it and you can create very subtle
color combinations and they're probably
a huge difference in that range
I feel like animation because if it does
cause motion if it is moving there's a
certain attention grabbing factor to
that that you just can't avoid no matter
how subtle the motion is so it's kind of
like there will be some some in some way
it's going to demand attention or
refocus attention and the question is
whether you're using it for something
people want to pay attention to like
this is the main reason why we ever had
animated banner ads right like if you
remember back in the day of old banner
ads they weren't like the animation in
them wasn't good I mean they could never
use enough colors to have a file size
that you know would look good it was
just all about having something off in
your peripheral vision like moving you
know they were like they had like
dancing banana is selling mortgages and
stuff those are not related it's just
cuz the banana could dance and then
maybe you'd look at that and want to get
a mortgage I have no idea if that ever
worked sounds crazy
um now in these more modern internet
times we use that for our newsletter
signup pop-ups and they just like kind
of flying at you or like zooming in and
rolling to get you to sign up for that
newsletter before you've even read a
word of content kind of the same thing
but we could also use that animation to
direct people's attention to a thing
they actually care about crazy idea but
Fitbit does this really well on their
site and on their iOS app as well we're
the only thing that moves on this site
the only thing that's animated is your
information of like how many steps did
you take did you beat your friend Lisa
today you know everything else there is
static can you just come to the site and
you're like hey it's all your
information that animates in even your
little badges I made sure to pick a very
good day so you could all think that I'm
very fit and walk a lot pretty effective
I mean I got three green badge things
obviously but everything that you even
that graph up in the top right all of
those you know gray lines to show you
like what spectrum you're looking at
those are already there the only thing
that comes in is is your is your
information they do this really well as
well in their iOS app but the design is
completely different completely
differently a completely different thing
but one thing they keep consistent is
the way they use motion which I thought
was a really interesting choice for them
so you go to the iOS app and you're like
how many steps did I take today and
again the only thing that animates in is
your actual data it's kind of funny in a
way because they've also since they've
only are only using animation for your
data there's also no like page
transitions when you go to a new day
you only know because new information
comes in which i think is kind of like
great you really stuck with your choices
um but even though the layout and the
screen size are completely different
they keep that consistent feel with the
animation and use it to draw attention
to the thing you actually care about
code pandas as well too
but sort of for maybe a less like of a
celebration kind of way
if you copan is a site where you can
like just try out code in the browser
you can write some HTML you can write
some JavaScript and CSS and then
immediately see it and like the little
pain beside you and you can share it all
these things but you no matter what to
make a code pen you have to write some
code and you're still in a browser so if
you wrote a bunch of code and then like
hit the back button or something you
could lose all your work and that would
really suck so if you're making a pen
and you forgot to turn on autosave and
hadn't haven't hit save yet but you're
actually actively working code pens
start shaking the Save button at you to
be like save your work please don't lose
it
I'll show you that too you're like dude
to do it it's like what are you doing I
mean the longer you don't save if you're
wondering if you're one of those people
it's like oh how long will this happen
the longer you don't save the bigger
that shake gets it's just like Oh save
your work please and I think this is a
really interesting use case for
animation because if all of their
buttons if all over the navigation
buttons shook at you and you hovered
over them we would all hate this site
and no one would use it you'd be like
why are you doing that that is that is
horrible worse UX ever but the fact that
they pair this very exaggerated motion
with something you care about like not
losing your work it's you're like oh
cool thank goodness thanks for telling
me
you know they made it really big and
really exaggerated to call your
attention to a thing you actually really
care about like saving so instead of
being like an obnoxious banner or pop-up
or whatever they're just like please
don't lose your work you're like oh
that's great that's a lot of a lot of
times I get questions about you like how
much animation is too much like how do I
know if I've done too much of it
and really they're like there's no like
hard answer to that there's no like well
if you shook it five times that's too
many though that might be a good rule I
don't know it's really all about the
context like the animation we find
acceptable here to remind us to save our
work is very different than the
animation we might find acceptable for
like you know an animal ever over
navigation or submitting a form it
really all comes down to the context
what the user is trying to do and how
focus the animation is on helping them
get that done perceived performance is
is I like to kind of consider like the
magic trick of animation because you can
use animation to make it seem like time
is going faster it's really it's like
our brains are just wonderful things you
know we actually can think that less
time has passed if we're feeling if you
know if we use if Isis designers fill
that time with something that's you know
making it seem like it might be it can
make like unavoidable weight seem
shorter you could feel like you're
waiting for less time even though
nothing has changed I think that's
really cool this is why we see a lot of
things like that skeleton content that
we see on like Facebook on slack on like
literally almost every site on the
internet now or these little pulsing
gray bars come like don't worry your
contents loading your contents loading
it's totally coming the best thing about
this is like the content those little
this those little alarm lines we're like
suggesting this might be a text post
right and then they got replaced with a
video but like as users we tend to not
care we're just like I'll call my
contents coming I got it
Facebook is loading real fast today and
then you're just like boom there's your
content so the reason we see those hints
of those little animated lines is that
idea that like something is happening
your content is almost here just keep
waiting a little longer and that feels
like it's faster then hat waiting the
exact same amount of time for your
content to load just seeing a plain
white page we also see it maybe a little
bit more subtly and things like loaders
like this is the Twitter loader when the
bird while you're loading are waiting
for your tweets the bird just kind of
hangs out and does little thing kind of
animate in and show you your tweets so
in this case I was on a super slow
connection so I still saw a spinner but
that idea of having that motion that's
like coming towards me and like bringing
my tweets to me makes it feel like I'm
waiting less time
another way folks get this done really
well is real is focusing your users on
the progress of what's happening not how
long they've been waiting so instead of
like having a zero to 100% thing I mean
that is progress but you're really kind
of letting them know like more
specifically what's happening Shopify
does this really well in their signup
thing when you make a new store someone
already had a store called Val's store
so I had to call mine super awesome
store I want to know who owns val store
I need to talk to them but as you're
creating your new store they give you
this little thing they're like we're
creating your store
step 1 like step 2 step 3 step 4 is your
store being done sorry to spoil it for
you I like I can pretty much guarantee
those things are not happening when
those come up I think those things are
probably all happening behind the scenes
but they weren't happening in that order
and they definitely weren't happening
when they came up but the fact that you
see that is focusing on you're like oh
I'm on stepped like two of whatever it's
making putting the Styles in my store
it's focusing you on the progress not on
how long you've been waiting so this
thing like setting up a brand new
Shopify store which I'm assuming is
going to take a certain number of
seconds no matter what right like they
can't just instantly create a whole new
set a whole new site for you that's a
place where they've recognized waiting
has to happen by focusing their user on
the progress it becomes less of a
waiting thing and more of like
excitement and anticipation of like yes
this is coming sooner I think loading is
super super interesting I've also talked
to some folks who sell a home design and
manage a site that sells some kind of
insurance and they were telling me that
they kind of it's almost the opposite of
this in a way where they made their site
too fast you could use their site to get
insurance quotes and they made it so you
could get your quote like instantly and
like like I think five seconds or
something maybe even less than that and
they found that like people didn't trust
it they didn't think they were real
quotes because it came too fast so they
made like a fake loader and like
intentionally made it so that always
took like at least 10 seconds or
something or some amount of seconds it's
probably some other number than that and
when they made people wait longer they
thought the information was more valid
which I'm like wow people are amazing
like it's so if we want everything
faster everything faster
you're not that because it can't be good
if it's too fast so the psychology of
loading I think is super super
interesting and I've run into some
interesting studies about it I mean
there's tons and tons but two that I
think are the most interesting recently
are ones like this one from bigoted labs
they call it experiments on loading how
long will you wait kind of sounds like
it could be a movie and in this
experiment they it's actually kind of a
mean experiment I mean they played
loaders for people that were loading
nothing
they weren't waiting for anything they
just wanted to see how long people would
watch the loaders and I won and I'm like
oh so clever but also so mean so they
had a whole variety of loaders they had
everything from like your generic
spinner to your generic like zero to
100% all the way to some like highly
customized highly animated loaders using
their vague at logo like something that
was clearly made just for that waiting
experience and they found that the
loaders that were more custom more not
necessarily more detailed exactly but
that were obviously ones that time went
into making them they were customized
for that situation for the Viggen labs
site that what they thought they were
loading people would wait longer for
them because they thought it was more I
think essentially because they felt it
was more trustworthy when they just saw
a generic spinner they were like oh
whatever who knows that this is
happening I'm done when they saw
something more customized they were
willing to wait longer Facebook is also
done some studies unloading this one is
interesting and I think gives a slightly
different dimension to the idea of
loading although they didn't really give
a lot of information on the study itself
this this article is kind of the only
one that talks about it but they found
what they said they found was that when
the loader looked like it was coming
from Facebook people blame Facebook for
being slow and when the loader icon like
animation looks like it was coming from
their phone they thought their phone was
being slow and you're like oh clever so
in a way like that's slightly different
than what the Viggen folks found where
they were like more customized people
wait longer Facebook's is kind of like
if it looks like it belongs to us you
blame us kind of thing so but the
psychology around loading is definitely
pretty complex and I think it's it's
definitely something worth looking into
because there's just some really
interesting things about it so loading
is is that like I don't know magical
place of
just interesting interesting things one
last thing I wanted to mention about
animation that I think is a super
important thing to do with it and super
important thing to consider about it is
something that not everyone considers to
be like a UX focus thing you're like I
design UX stuff why do I care about
storytelling but no matter what kind of
product you're working on no matter what
kind of site you're working on there is
like some specific personality some
specific message some sort of like thing
you want to embody across your whole
design and animation should be just as
much a part of getting that across as
any other part of your design like well
you know the same things you would
consider when you pick your type and
your colors and all those things like
that messaging should also come through
in your animation
it doesn't always there's some pretty
fun exceptions to this all the time a
lot of people just want to like oh just
throw some animation in there it'll be
great it's like well you should throw in
some animation that makes sense for the
rest of your design one of my favorite
examples of this is a little bit old but
that's okay because it's an awesome
example maybe not but it was just one
that bothered me for like six years or
something this is the dots game an older
version of the dots game they have newer
ones but if you used to play this one or
have never seen it before this is what
it what the settings menu look like so
when you're going through the settings
menu you've got this very kind of like
pointed bounce everything's really
bouncy like it really like sharp balance
as you're going through all the settings
and that motion is really similar to the
game like the motion in the game and the
dots come through is just like dots and
dots you're like yeah a game this is
great it's like very bouncy a little bit
reminiscent of like Muppet dancing if
you watch Grover when you were little
you know very playful very fun perfect
for games less perfect for Apple same
motion different brand what's like I
hang out with my Mac products quite a
bit maybe more than I should my parents
like to make fun of me that I just owned
everything in the Apple store but
they're probably right but like my
MacBook never moves like that my MacBook
is not like bouncing around nothing that
I own from Apple is just bouncing around
like that like their whole branding is
about being really like sleek and like
sophisticated and that bounce just drove
me crazy for like the four years it was
on their site because it just didn't fit
and it's it's not like anyone stopped
buying Apple products because of that
animation but when they fixed it and
made it something more like this a few
years later it's like this actually
feels more like Apple it's like the
subtle thing you're like ooh apple shiny
so much better of course they completely
ditched this when they release the
iPhone 6 so it's it's long gone but I
was so happy they fixed it before they
got rid of it because I would complain
to like everyone I ever met about that
Apple menu which might explain why I
don't have a lot of friends so your
choice of easing the way the way your
animation moves is like just as
important of a consideration when it
comes to the message you're sending
across as the purpose that is there for
so you want to be paying attention to
both of those things to have that nice
cohesive kind of look to what you're
doing this is one last thing I find that
making good animation is better when you
kind of like expose yourself to more
good animation we all have sites we like
to go to to find like beautifully
designed like websites and we're like I
want my site to look like that or be as
good as designed as that I think it's
great to do that for motion too so two
places I found that are really great for
doing that as part of the title which is
all about oh it helps if you actually
you know hit the button that's me
talking to myself not you you guys don't
have to hit a button but I did there we
go it's art of the title is to tie it
it's it's a title all about sites or
it's a site all about title designs for
moving in TV they interview a lot of the
designers behind the scenes and they all
talk about things like how they use
imagery and type to tell a story and
you're like holy crap that's my job - Oh
crazy it's a super informative there and
really great stuff they also have an
entire section of Saul Bass titles which
is like the best part of the internet I
think there's also user interface who
have actually changed their URLs to just
be user interface calm not you why I Oh
for some reason that one is not
redirecting today but maybe it'll come
back and they're more focused on web
stuff specifically where they actually
kind of have things in categories of
like here's how people have done drag
and drop and interactions here's how
people have done like loading animations
and it's a nice place to kind of go if
you're like I
think you know I've decided I want to
animate this interaction but how should
I do it and that blank page syndrome
just it's easier to see kind of an
example of what other people have done
it's always helpful like spark those
ideas as opposed to just staring at your
screen that's blank and being like oh I
don't know what to do
so if designing interface animation
sounds like a fun thing to you I totally
wrote a book about it it talks a lot
about animation and features as many
pictures as my dog as I was allowed to
fit in I tried to sneak as many by the
publisher as possible my glue
look over there here's other dog picture
so you can get that from Rosenfeld and
you should totally tell him all the dog
pictures were the best for us so with
that thanks so much for listening and
let's let's do some Q&A
[Applause]